quedan pocos rastros del mayor incendio
registrado en la historia de cuba El
barrido de la zona con maquinaria pesada
augura un nuevo comienzo en esta zona de
matanzas un polo Industrial clave para
el desempeño del país en la
conflagración se perdieron totalmente
cuatro tanques de gran capacidad y con
ellos una reserva de 145.000 metros
cúbicos de combustible a pesar de las
labores de recuperación la base de
supertanqueros sigue trabajando ahora
tenemos menos capacidad almacenamiento
de Cruz pero no hemos dejado dar el
servicio con un esfuerzo inmenso de que
tenemos que seguir trabajando para
recuperarnos en medio de la crisis
energética que sufre el país sumado a
las sanciones externas el funcionamiento
de la instalación es decisivo
eso no va a suceder no no sucedió no va
a suceder en 66 millones de dólares se
estiman los daños ocasionados por el
incendio la fase actual de recuperación
que incluye demoliciones y retiro de
escombros Avanza en un 70% el ajetreo
constante hace recordar a los vecinos
del lugar el fatídico momento voy a mi
familia y salimos corriendo por el rico
bajo la lluvia que ellos fue terrible
descalzo con sin nada dejamos casas
abiertas y todo y corrimos hasta de la
termoeléctrica para allá como un
kilómetro el fuego dejó 16 fallecidos 14
de ellos sin posibilidad de
identificación el gobierno cubano
anunció la reconstrucción de la base de
supertanqueros de matanzas con la ayuda
de Venezuela quien brindará su
experiencia y medios para lograrlo